hello and welcome to your first look at
sunset OverDrive's co-op multiplayer
chaos squad it's an a player co-op mode
that lets players craft their experience
by voting on a variety of mission types
to tackle in the open world and all this
culminates in a massive night defense
which is harder or easier depending on
which missions you've completed if you
win you'll earn yourself some awesome
rewards like cash special vanity items
and even weapons that you can lug back
with you to the single-player game so
you're playing single-player you drop
off a grind rail strut up to the nearest
photo booth and enter multiplayer with
the same clothing the same amp same
everything as your character from the
single-player at the start you and your
ragtag band are gonna get to mission
options to vote on you conquer it the
two new ins crossbow and they'll have
different objectives and be in separate
locations from the first round so the
result is that each chaos squad
experience feels unique as you're going
through the
after a few rounds of boating and
slaying and chaos arboost kidding it's
time for you and your team to face off
in the main event night two cents this
is where you'll fend off enemies and
protect your vats of overcharged by not
only using your weapons traversal and
amps or by placing traps as well
before each wave you'll have a bit of
time to place your traps but if you've
made a horrible miscalculation you can
move and place them during each wave as
well and then the enemy's attack and
what comes next is an assault of eight
players simultaneously jumping and
shooting grinding and exploding nearly
every damn thing in sight each wave
brings an increasingly difficult and new
variety of enemies to your door and
remember the more chaos you gathered in
the open world missions the harder it's
gonna be you're gonna get way more
chances have better rewards than those
would seems who preferred it to below
after the dust settles and you hopefully
bask in victory you and your bounty can
go back to the single-player game or
enter the chaos again so that's chaos
squad sunset overdrive
ultimate party where your custom single
player character can join up to seven
friends online and choose which unique
mission to take on in the open world of
sunset city it's a brand new experience
every time and it all builds up to one
massive night defense that's customized
based on your choices thank you so much
for watching and we hope you've enjoyed
your first look at chaos squad and
sunset overdrive follow us on Twitter
and Facebook and we'll keep you up to
date on all the latest sunset malarkey
from all of us here and insomniac games
see you next time xbox one now starting
at 399